hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game played in 1961 between
international master from Spain Roman
Turin albero and Michael Tao now a few
days ago my channel hit 300 thousand
subscribers and as it is customary on
this channel when we reach a certain
milestone we will show a game played by
mikhail tal as he's the sole protector
of this channel you can see a very nice
photo of him up there on the right above
my head and i also mentioned that it'd
be best to probably wait a few days ago
and as on 18th of november latvia is
celebrating their 100th birthday so 100
years ago today a lot i declared its
independence and i know what you're
thinking why if we did the video for
when estonia was celebrating their 100th
birthday and we've shown a very nice
game where paul carrots beets and none
other than mikhail tal so here it would
make sense to show a game where Michael
Tao beats Paul Karras but we've already
shown such very nice game during our
coverage of the 1959 candidates in case
you haven't seen it all you just want to
check it out in honor of Latvia's 100th
birthday it will be the first thing you
will see in the description below so
Paul Harris versus Michael Todd during
the 1959 candidates and also I like to
remind everyone after we reach a certain
milestone there will be also a link in
the description below it will be the
second link you see in the description
it is my video for her that I created
for celebrating when my channel reached
1000 subscribers so it's always nice to
you know get back and see how it all
started happening and it is also a very
nice reminder to perhaps some of you who
are interested in doing YouTube I don't
you know get too worked up about what
your audio quality is like what your
video quality is like because that video
if you check it out you will see that
I'm not even using a camera I'm using a
$2.00 microphone and I haven't really
prepared all that much I just came like
really tired after a long day at work
and I decided to show her a nice tall
game on the Internet
so that being said I'm sure you're in
Latvia
in Riga in the capital of Latvia you're
having like a great party today I can
only imagine I've seen that the I've
read I will also include a link to a
website that talks more about how Latvia
will celebrate this great milestone I
read that it will not be only like a
huge celebration in in Riga but also in
the four regions of Latvia and also they
are preparing a tour around the world
giving all different kinds of programs
they are planning 900 different programs
around the world and most of them will
be free and available on television so
surely if you are enjoying this you know
feel free to send a few photos I will
definitely show it in tomorrow's video
or or when I feel a feeling appropriate
but that being said here we have a very
nice game it was played like we already
mentioned in 1961 in the in the second
European team championship and the the
championship was won by Soviet Union and
that's not very surprising just to show
you how very not surprising it was this
is the team that came representing the
Soviet Union so onboard one you have
Mikhail Botvinnik then Michael Tao for 3
Paul Kerr a sport for Tigran Petrosian
vasily smyslov Viktor Korchnoi f'ing
Geller marked a Man of La Fleur gave ski
s/m informant and as substitute boards
alexander toll and vladimir buggy roof
so this is like a really scary team and
it's not really a surprise that they've
won first place and already you can see
that currently my channel is now on
three hundred and five thousand
subscribers so really really a nice
growth you know if if this continues t
series will not be the only thing
pewdiepie will have to worry about
obviously that that is a that is a joke
but you know steadily growing III enjoy
it and thank you all very much for that
so on to the game like we said tell face
is a Roman Turin albero one of the
strongest international masters in Spain
at that time he he won the Spanish
championship twice
and he represented Spain in plenty of
Olympic competitions so let's check out
this very nice game our Roman opens it
with c4 and tal replies would be five so
going after the center which is
definitely a very principled decision we
have knife to c3 and now d6 let me just
fix that g3 a preparing to fianchetto
the light square bishop and now f5 by
tall D for an early strike in the center
and here tall has to make a decision
whether he just wants to continue
developing maybe Bishop to e7 maybe
Knight to f6 maybe even capture if you
capture for example pawn captures here
then Queen captures on d4 and you will
not be able to push away the Queen just
yet with 96 it was a very important to
play Knight f6 before that here if you
just develop a knight with an attack on
the Queen then Queen to e3 could be very
unpleasant after black defense in 95 and
now already black will have some
problems developing because you can to
just continue Knight of 6 white will
capture your Bishop is paint here you
will have to ruin your King side so here
after d4 at all doesn't go into all of
this he rather pushes efore unlike in a
game Viktor Korchnoi yesterday he
decided to release the tension in the
center a bit early here Tao decides to
complicate things
we have f3 wanting to resolve the
situation in the center immediately and
now tau continues developing Knight to
f6 Bishop to g2 and now comes each
captures on f3 Knight captures on f3 and
now g6 and here white castles so now as
you can see it all didn't achieve all
that much out of the opening if anything
he's even worse as his King is still
stuck in the center he didn't really
develop any of his pieces as you can see
and white already has two knights in the
game a very nice team Carroll Bishop the
rook occupies a semi-open
F file and ok the F file is closed for a
moment but white will be able to break
it open with E for anytime he pleases
tile goes the birth of the g7 the Fe and
ghettos his dark square Bishop prepares
the castle and as his King is still in
the center of white makes
very principled decision and he plays
efore he wants to open up the lines of
attack as tasking is still is still in
the center F captors on e4 by tal and
now we have Knight to g5 opening up now
a triple attack against the d4 pawn so
he will be able to get it back
also the bishop is a very strong here
you have to be careful if this pawn is
recaptured then this diagonal becomes
very strong ideas like Bishop to d5 will
be available in the future this night
will perhaps be able to go to six to f7
it's a very dangerous position for towel
but towel doesn't mind we have castle
oops not King f8 we have castles by Tom
and here White has to make a decision
okay you're playing the former world
champion I say former because this game
was played in June of 1961 and towel
already resolved the matters with Botwin
akin in March of 1961
so here towel is already a former world
champion and here Knight captures and g4
was played but it was played using the
night from g5 a slight improvement would
have been nice C captures on e4 why
mister albero decided not to go with
this is very interesting of course you
always have to consider what happens if
h6 is played but here such a thing
wouldn't be possible if h6 here this
losses by force due to Knight captures
on f6 with Czech Bishop captures and
Bishop to d5 check now the bishop is
controlling both a 6 and f7 and after
the King moves now of course you see the
move how this hypothetical line could
have finished if not feel free to pause
the video it's actually a very nice
puzzle for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are once again
an excellent solver of hypothetical
lines that never actually happened but
not Knights to e6 or anything like that
it's actually Bishop capture some b7 a
very nice idea I was simply trying to
take away d6 square because the bishop
captures then 96 wins the Queen and if
Bishop doesn't capture then you're just
gonna have to capture a knight and then
you lose the rook on a 8 and now white
is really winning this game
so when deciding whether to recaptured
upon with the g5 night or the c3 Knight
perhaps the c3 night was a slight
improvement our Canaanite ji captures on
e4 we have night captures on e4 rook
captures on f8 we have Queen captures on
f8 and now Knight captures on e4
so okay white is still better slightly
in development and tal still has to
figure out how to properly develop his
Queen side and he decides he does it in
the best way possible Knight to c6 going
after the d4 pawn forcing White's reply
Bishop to e3 defending the d4 pawn and
now we have Bishop to f5 so tall just
has to get his last piece into the game
the rockin a8 and his forces will be
fully mobilized Queen to d2 white also
wants to do the same he wants to bring
his rook into the game ideas like rook
to Bishop to h6 might be possible in the
future if the Queen moves and if the
pressure against the d4 pawn will not be
so great tile develops rook to e8 and
now with a double attack on this night
and here you have to really decide how
to properly play this position in the
game Knight to g5 was played as the
night is now attacked twice but again a
slight improvement for white would have
been a rook to f1 not allowing bishop to
capture as the Queen would be hanging on
f8 but it's not an easy choice to make
because here after Queen to e7 now
there's a triple attack against the
night and of course you can't move it
because the bishop would be under attack
but here remove white most likely didn't
see because if he had a rock - f1 is a
slight improvement to what was played
Bishop to f2 would have been a very nice
move because now if the captures
captures and captures then rook to e1 is
very strong if the Queen moves you
either have to move the Queen or and
then lose the rook on e on e 8 with
check King moves and now you just
escaped with sorry about that being the
exchange up and if not after rook to e1
you can simply capture the rook and
claim that you will be that this is
playable after Knight captures on d4
simply because you have a rook and the
night for the Queen
but okay after rook to e8 a white
doesn't find the strong rook f1 he goes
Knight to g5 simply getting the knight
out of the way and here black really
should act immediately there's really no
time for moves like Queen to e7 now
white will just be able to develop but
as this is a at our game I'm showing you
you of course know what style decided to
play but it's a very intriguing move top
played rook captures on e3 and no of
course you can't capture on e3 if you
capture it then of course Bishop
captures will win you the Queen and the
game but it's interesting what stall
actually allows by playing group
captures on e3 here Tao allows the
bishop to d5 check and ok this was
played in the game you don't have the
option of returning the material with
rook to e6 if you do this then Bishop
captures Bishop captures Knight captures
and after the Queen moves you will
simply grab the bishop as well and now
you are up in material you have Europe
the exchange and you will have no
problems winning this game so here after
Bishop to d5 Tao actually allowed this
King to h8 and now his opponent just
played Knight to f7 already feeling very
good about himself
I have tile in a deadlock I'm just gonna
continue checking him because here if
King g8 then a knight to a6 check it's a
double check from the bishop and the
night and here Roman Turin albero was
most likely hoping for a perpetual a
draw by perpetual check but it all had
something else in mind when he played
rook captures on e3 here tal simply
played Queen captures on f7 as I mean it
is only a queen
Bishop captures on f7 and now comes Luke
to d3 rook to d3 a very nice move you
could also start with Bishop captures on
d4 which would most likely result in a
similar position as one roof to d3 is
played but this is something tall often
does in his game so when you can achieve
the exact same position via different
moves you always want to play the move
that allows your opponent to make as
many mistakes as possible here it's not
such an occasion here Queen to d2 was
played which is the best reply from
white but white could have easily tried
something like Queen 2a
and then he would face a bishop captures
on the forecheck King moves and now Bush
of three III an attacking move on the
Queen and after Queen to h4 guarding
against the bishop to h3 and also
threatening Queen to f6 checkmate King
the g7 defending and now whatever move
white makes a rope to d4 will simply
trap the white queen so whatever you
play here doesn't really matter Ruby for
traps the Queen and it is all over but
okay white played the correct response
Queen to e2 and now we have Bishop
captures on d4 with Czech king g2 and
now comes Knight to e5 closing away the
e-file from the White Queen and as you
can see tells forces are you know
happily hanging out in front of mr.
Alberto's King and it's not a very
pleasant position to play with white you
have to decide how to approach this here
rook to d1 was played trying to get a
nice rook exchange here if you go for
something like Bishop to defy which is
again a very interesting move black will
respond with c6 simply getting trying to
get your Bishop out of the way and then
you could try rook to d1 and here after
pawn captures rook captures and Bishop
captures on d3 Queen moves and Bishop to
b4 check you will now have two bishops
and the night for the Queen still a much
more enjoyable game for black it would
be it's hard to say if white could
wiggle out of this one now but butter of
the d5 was not the idea that was played
here look the d1 was played and now
telegin avoids the rook trade would have
rook to e3 and we reach the final
moments of the game with Queen to d2
black a white could still have hoped to
try something here but after the move
that was played in the game Queen to f1
here it is now all over but to feel free
to pause the video here and win this
game for towel and you know help us
celebrate this a lot 100th birthday
properly and also this milestone of me
reaching 300 thousand subscribers for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you know let's get this
party started and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show here top
played Bishop to e4 check
and now there's really not all that much
you can do here you don't want to go to
g1 as then you're gonna face a lot of
nasty discoveries so h1 is off-limits
due to the bishop you have to go to h3
then comes rook to f3 your queen is
under attack but also the bishop on f7
is hanging now not so important now
because your Bishop on d4 is also
hanging here Queen to e2 was played and
now I'll simply finishes it off with
another Bishop to a5 check and it was in
this position that International Master
from Spain Roman Turin Alvaro resigned
the game as now if you go back with King
to g2 then we have the exact same
position we had a few moves ago only the
rook is not on d3 the rook is on f3 and
now a move like group 2 f2 is definitely
possible because now after Queen
captures Bishop capture screen captures
you will face Knight captures on f7
black will be up in material he will
have a knight and a bishop for a rook
and also he will be up upon so an easily
winning endgame and an even greater idea
comes after this Bishop to a5 check if a
white continues with King to h4 what
Tull had in mind here is actually Bishop
to e3 and here
whatever whatever a move white plays
it's over
the g3 move takes away the g5 Square
from the White King and now whatever you
try and play let's say you play a rope
to f1 then it's a 4th sequence g5 check
King to h5 Bishop to g4 check King to h6
and now a nice checkmate with a knight
Knight captures on f7 white the White
King has nowhere to go but should be
covering h5 pawn is covering g6 and of
course these squares are covered by the
King so a wonderful checkmate and I'm
definitely definitely gonna use this for
the thumbnail of this video so yeah
there you have it
Roman Turin albero vs. Michael towel
1961 European team championship once
again we can we can marvel the lineup
the Soviet Union brought to represent
them it's really a a magnificent team
and I would like to thank Carlos a go
which David Turnbull
yotz a column arts Patrick Lauria and
John Malpass for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
do check out everything I mentioned in
the description below a Dallas game
against Paul Karason the 1959 candidates
tournament my video for when my channel
reached 1000 subscribers it's you know
it feels weird asking you to watch it as
it's a pretty bad video but you know it
might actually get you motivated when
you see you know the evolution of my
channel from there then until now and
yeah also check out the link for the
official Latvia 100th anniversary and
the program it offers if you are
anywhere in the vicinity and yeah I
think y'all for being such excellent
subscribers and I haven't decided yet
will there be like a chess tournament or
a tournament somewhere else or or how we
will celebrate this but I don't know
it's this seems like too early to
celebrate you know I may be maybe better
wait just for the 500,000 subscriber
milestone but we'll see you know feel
free to offer your suggestions as usual
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos you're thankful for watching and
I will see you soon the next game we
will show of course is Game seven of the
2018 World Championship match thank you
all and I will see you soon